mi ero dimenticato quanto era bello
vestirsi come l'anti sesso meraviglioso
ragazzi di bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj oggi
siamo tornati sulla chitarra e strano
che abbiano fatto seguito di un gioco
del genere non me l'aspettavo mai nella
vita però bene allora parte la
musichetta che mi ami mimici masturba
ray sopra move jump
sì sì se la stessa cosa e va bene chi
cazzo è questo perché c'è il mio zio del
giovane sean perde ne andiamo andiamo
andiamo forte 6 cavani è questa la torre
va bella quindi un picciolo peso regala
un cazzo finissimo buongiorno fratello
domanda semplice la domanda polo
semplice perché quindi allora la trama
di questo gioco è sempre la stessa in
realtà è quella di scendere da questa
torre fantastica e delle altre si entra
nei porter a c'avevo investiti nel baule
per perfetto michia non pensavo mi sono
fatto seguito veramente bene ragazzi
allora la chitarra 2 dobbiamo scendere
da questa torre è fantastica arrivare al
piano terra questa è la trama guardi e
se usciva un nudo non era un bello
spettacolo però in questo caso lo è se
la picchio non succede niente bene
questi sono alleati fantastico allora la
prima porta da scegliere oggi e tra
queste tre tra l'altro qua c'è una
chiazza di sangue che promette molto
bene di entrare qua dentro stesso per
curiosità giorno
è mattina io sono vestito io sono più
bello di questi non volevo disturbare
stato bello conoscerli bene stiamo qua
dentro che c'è lo scudo salve che è
d'artagnan
ok non posso farmi ma perché non
possiamo interagire ragazze che cosa
[Musica]
come mentre si stava illustrando
l'armatura e tragicamente inciampato
cosa è successo va bene
bello questo gioco sempre più bello è
questo gioco gli mancava lo slash e
slash perfetta voi non eravate quelli di
prima quindi caccia ai vi spostate
importante che andiamo avanti ragazzi
poi fontesecca buongiorno ok quindi devo
portare una non lo sono scritto sul
braccio tra l'altro avendolo trovare
anton kaufman e in città va bene la
faccia sveglia con questo presepe ha
quindi posso andare poco in giro per il
villaggio di persone tra l'altro ma che
figo città perfetto la salve devo
sentire hagrid
certo motivo del perché tu mi stai su k
tela la barba ogni tanto un consiglio
può anche ragazza parte il fatto che non
ho capito il perche eva è la madonna che
cazzo è ma cos'è aia gli hanno spaccato
un dente va bene ma tu saresti indiana
jones peloso spiegamento air indiana
jones peloso mi avete spaccato un dente
ben dovete pagare il dentista bastardi
basta che palle quanta gente che le
scarse ray palle funziona lo scudo ok
non ho bisogno perché sono forte
fantastico ragazzi ho fatto fuori 800
uomini non sono anche del bene perché è
per quale motivo prova ben più sveglio
di me durante le lezioni di scienze sei
tu anton cartman venditori di cappelli
aton cartman vuoi avere uno di questi ma
cosa ve li posso comprare 9 gioco
dell'anno ragazzi voglio un polipo in
testa subito a posso vendere i miei
capelli cosa tu sei tutto è scemo a
posso equipaggiarlo si perfetto perfetto
è esattamente quello che volevo ragazzi
serviva questa roba antica ma perché mi
sta parlando un barbone perché quel
barbone nonno ciak da questa è un chiaro
riferimento è più miss comunque lo
ignoro miriamo al barbone ma che cazzo
ma che si sta facendo il figo con la
tipa ma non riesce a sollevare
l'incudine fantastico
va bene
posso comprare le mazze bellissimo buon
gioco dell'anno
ok cazzo per poco non arrivava a
prendere questa qua che sfiga a macero
beh va beh
eva breve babak tornerò quando avevo i
soldi tocco è anche un caso ma non non è
un tocca i ragazzi non lo trovo sto tipo
che cazzo da fare
vuoi una caramella no cane parole ma
poverino lavoro bimbo ragazzi mi
spiegate dove dovrebbe essere quel tipo
che non lo trovo mai porca vacca live o
no da altri prego ci avevo sperato
secondo me anton cup ma non so perché ma
è questo qua secondo me non so perché ho
mica ce l'aveva la faccia da anton
cartman cosa deve avere
devo prenderli 1 rig recuperali un
orologio aiuta anton a vincere un gioco
di carte ma come perché lì ad anton
quale carta pescherà va bene gli ok p ma
che cazzo di gioco è questo ma perché ma
cosa sta giocando santo iddio
ma che cos'è sta roba b perfetto
hai vinto zio ha posto era quello
l'orologio di cui stai parlando bene non
poteva essere una roba da polso no va
bene scorta anton craftsman dal re bene
a lui mi segue con che che gioco dei
settimi pressi 10 di d oro che prendo
l'arma quella grossa forte di presto
cioè dai che ti ho fatto vincere inoltre
cazzo zia nessuno mi presterò a roma per
niente oro nella pazienza di avanti vai
vai vai
grazie a dio hanno inventato gli orologi
soprattutto l'ora c'è sullo smartphone
il giorno dopo al giorno d'oggi salver
box che se ancora più grosso degli altri
oddio oddio oddio oddio no allora non se
n'è accorto lui cazzo bene proprio
mentre sono circondato doveva andar giù
quello ahia ahia
sono fortissimi che tattica da vero
guerriero ragazzi è stata di capua
funziona da dio ha funzionato da dio non
so come sembra che abbia fatto cadere
qualcosa ma ma va ragazzi devo fare
qualcosa di nuovo ma non ho capito cosa
ma nel dubbio vado a prendermi l'arma
nuova foto e sega ragazzi miei 110 e ci
siamo porca eva che chi coduri a posso
vendere la mia vecchia spada no vabbè
sica equipaggio con la nuova far vedere
quante grossa madonna che figo
bellissimo trova un cavallo e trova una
mappa perfetto allora non devo più
accompagnare le cose il tipo da re
perché non sono cancellato dal braccio
perché è morto giustamente devo andare a
trovare qualcosa che non ho capito cosa
prova beghe trono ma poi trovare le
cavallo va bene il cavallo eccolo
perfetto ciao zio
sì non so cosa è che qualora la domanda
porca [ __ ]
ma ecco la mappa grande 15 orecchie di
di goblin califfo tutti i goblin
torrevecchia c'è la vecchia torre quella
dell'altro gioco che sta gente
porca vacca monteforte la mia arma e
vabbè mica sono un killer
porca eva lo butta giù ma ancora
reporter dalla scopa comunque old tower
e volevo vedere la vecchia torre c'è
scritto con subito e questo è un goblin
mi chiamo amore porca eva ma lasciato
con un dente solo come possibile è vero
e presso la vecchia torre cazzo sono
quasi morto raga come fece recupera vita
porca eva ok come faccio a recuperar
vita fermi già a zio o no no tranquillo
ti faccio niente e lui recupera vita
come si recupera ora kg goblin perfetto
so come si recuperi la vita però va bene
narrativa pezzo di merda no no no no no
no no no ho dei ricordi del delle palle
di lasciar perdere allora devo riuscire
a tornare sano e salvo in città perché
non ho più denti e senza i denti o in
teoria dovrei morire
quindi se per caso qualcuno mi sfiora mi
soffia in faccia io muoio allora fa mi
tornando al tipo dove era il tipo che
vendeva le mappe tipo di un'unica eccola
qua perfetto cioe orecchio o tutto ma
santo iddio ce l'ho ma anche a solo e
soltanto il cavallo che non ho ben
capito cosa devo fare per prenderlo però
c'è il bambino che mi chiede solo una
caramella non so cosa ti serva zio però
te la do della donna cariati denti io
non ce li ho mai visti schengen
[Musica]
fantastico gioco della vita
ma come forza fatto di cavallo fa ma no
ma non si fa
porca vacca tutto questo per una
caramella tra l'altro è niente ragazzi
adesso che il tipo e distratto posso
entrare in quest'edificio fantastico e
trovare i cavalli let's go che tra
l'altro sono fuori avere che storico
quello che questo primo episodio di
lucky tower 2 che sembra più
intelligente di quello di prima ci
voleva poco è però va bene ragazzi miei
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
molto più lungo rigoli prima quindi devo
farci l'episodi per forza però però che
ora sui temi del momento è un mi piace
anche i vari social che come il mio
totale descrizione sa se si discute ci
vediamo così unito e da ragazzi